Welcome back to your Danish citizenship exam companion.
This is Chapter One, Episode 3, Part Two.
Now the world goes to war.
1914 to 18 saw the First World War rage between Europe's great powers.
Denmark avoided becoming directly involved.
The years that followed were marked by a highly deadly influenza epidemic, and by political unrest in both Denmark and the rest of the world.
Many European countries developed into dictatorships.
In the 1930s, the world was in deep economic crisis.
In Denmark too, unemployment grew sharply.
That triggered many conflicts on the labour market and gave the Social Democrats great support.
It also motivated the old parties to find solutions together, which helped ensure that anti-democratic ideologies never really gained support in Denmark.
In 1914 the First World War broke out.
On one side stood Germany, Austria-Hungary and the Ottoman Empire.
On the other side stood France, Russia, Great Britain, Italy, and later also the USA.
Neutral Denmark lay geographically close to the fronts of the war, but was not directly affected.
Denmark was neutral, and was never occupied by German troops in the First World War.
The German occupation of Denmark came only in the Second World War, from 1940 to 1945.
After pressure from Germany, Denmark did, in 1914, choose to lay mines in some of the Danish waters.
Germany's purpose was to stop British warships from sailing into the Baltic Sea and thereby threatening Germany from there.
But the minefields could also stop German ships from sailing through the Danish straits.
One Danish population group became particularly involved in the First World War: the Danish-minded Schleswigers south of the border, who had become German citizens after Denmark's loss of Schleswig in the Second Schleswig War in 1864.
In total, about six thousand Danish South Jutlanders died in German war service during the First World War.
The Danish colonies in the West Indies also came into focus because of the war.
The USA feared that Germany might occupy the Danish West Indies, and therefore offered the Danish government in 1915 to buy Saint Thomas, Saint Croix and Saint John.
After a referendum in Denmark, the islands were sold in 1917 for twenty-five million dollars.
In return for the sale, the US government recognised that Greenland belonged fully and completely to Denmark.
Toward the end of the war, in 1918, the world and Denmark were hit by a very aggressive, contagious and deadly influenza virus, which got the name the Spanish Flu.
The disease did not originate in Spain at all, but got its name because it was Spanish newspapers that first wrote about it.
Because Denmark did not take part directly in the First World War, the country was better equipped to fight the disease, with a population that was better nourished and a health service that was less burdened than those of the many warring countries.
Even so, the Danish authorities could not do much.
Little was known about the disease, and for example no vaccine could be developed.
Many influenza patients also got pneumonia on top, which, before penicillin was discovered in 1928, they often died of.
The Danish Health Authority, Sundhedsstyrelsen, tried through leaflets to give the population advice on, among other things, good hygiene and on avoiding contact with each other, and some schools and entertainment venues closed down.
But all this was not enough to get the disease under control, and it hit the country in several waves in the period 1918 to 20.
A special feature of the Spanish Flu is that it largely killed relatively young people.
Most of the dead were between twenty and forty years old.
In total, the disease took up to fifty million lives, including about fifteen thousand in Denmark.
Now to the reunification.
Germany lost the First World War.
This made it possible for Denmark to demand back the primarily Danish-minded areas of Schleswig.
In 1920, the population in North Schleswig and Central Schleswig voted, in two different referendums, on whether it wished to belong to Germany or Denmark.
The vote in North Schleswig took place in February 1920.
A large majority voted for North Schleswig to be reunited with Denmark.
At the vote in March 1920 in Central Schleswig, where Flensburg was the largest town, a large majority on the other hand decided that the area should remain under Germany.
On the fifteenth of June, 1920, the border was formally moved south from the Kongeå river to the present border between Denmark and Germany.
North Schleswig, now called Sønderjylland, South Jutland, was thereby reunited with Denmark.
The return of South Jutland to Denmark is called the Reunification, Genforeningen.
But there is still a German minority, in 2020 about fifteen thousand, on the Danish side of the border, and a Danish minority, in 2020 about fifty thousand, on the German side.
The rights of these minorities were laid down in 1955 in the Copenhagen-Bonn Declarations, which has secured peaceful development in the border region.
Christian the Tenth rode across the border in 1920.
Shortly before the Reunification, Denmark experienced, in connection with the Easter Crisis, Påskekrisen, its most serious constitutional crisis in recent times.
Before that, King Christian the Tenth, who reigned from nineteen twelve to forty-seven, and the government had for a long time disagreed.
It was especially the disagreement about the new border to Germany that triggered the Easter Crisis.
The king thought the government, despite the referendum results, should try to get more of Schleswig back to Denmark than just North Schleswig.
The government rejected this.
At Easter 1920, Christian the Tenth dismissed the government because of this disagreement.
This happened even though the government did not have a majority against it in the Folketing.
The king's conduct during the Easter Crisis in 1920 triggered big demonstrations and political protests, and was described by parts of the daily press as a coup.
More people began to talk about abolishing the monarchy altogether.
The crisis blew over when the king and the political leaders, after intense negotiations, agreed to appoint a new temporary government and call a new election.
Since then, royal power has not interfered directly in politics.
Finally, the crisis years.
In 1917 the Bolsheviks, the communists, took power in Russia, which was transformed into the Soviet Union.
Fascism and Nazism gained ground in, for example, Italy in 1922 and in Germany in 1933, and many other European countries got authoritarian regimes during the 1920s and 1930s.
All of it expressed a movement in a non-democratic direction.
But in Denmark, it succeeded in holding on to democracy.
At the same time, a very serious international economic event took place in this period.
It was the stock market crash on Wall Street in New York in October 1929.
Share prices fell sharply, and the economic crisis spread to the rest of the world.
In Denmark, the country's biggest industry, agriculture, was especially hard hit.
The prices of grain and meat fell dramatically.
Thousands of farmers were forced to sell their farms because they did not earn enough money.
Unemployment rose sharply, and reached over thirty percent at the beginning of the 1930s.
In 1924, the cigar sorter Thorvald Stauning had become Denmark's first Social Democratic prime minister, in the year 1924.
This government, which lasted two years, until 1926, also included the country's first female minister.
Her name was Nina Bang, and she was minister of education.
So both the first Social Democratic prime minister and the first female minister date from 1924.
In 1929, the Social Democrats formed a government again, this time together with the Social Liberal Party.
The government tried to ease the crisis through various interventions.
On the thirtieth of January, 1933, coincidentally the same day Adolf Hitler became chancellor in Germany, the government and Venstre made the so-called Kanslergade Agreement, Kanslergadeforliget.
It got its name because the decisive negotiations took place at Prime Minister Stauning's residence in Kanslergade in Copenhagen.
The Kanslergade Agreement was a far-reaching settlement that took into account the interests of both employers and workers.
The agreement prevented lower wages for the workers, but banned strikes for one year.
It was also necessary to support agriculture, which was hard hit by the economic crisis.
The agreement made it easier for farmers to borrow money, so they avoided going bankrupt.
At the same time, the Danish krone was devalued, which means its value was lowered.
This made it easier to sell agricultural goods to Great Britain.
And as part of the agreement, a so-called social reform was also carried out, which extended the population's social rights and created more uniform rules for when the individual citizen could get financial help from the public, for example as a result of unemployment or illness.
Here's your recap for Episode Three.
Venstre is the farmers' party, and the Social Democrats are the workers' party.
In 1924, Stauning became the first Social Democratic prime minister, and Nina Bang the first female minister.
Stauning led governments again from 1929, through the crisis of the 1930s.
The Spanish Flu came at the end of the First World War.
Denmark was never occupied in the First World War.
DA is the employers' organisation.
Women's international day of struggle is the eighth of March, from 1921.
The Kanslergade Agreement was about the economic crisis.
The first railway opened in 1847, in the 1840s.
The International Workers' Association was founded in 1871, the Battle of the Fælleden took place in 1872, and the September Compromise in 1899, the root of the Danish Model.
The Change of System came in 1901.
The Social Liberal Party was formed in 1905, and the Conservative People's Party in 1915 to 16.
Women's vote: 1915, in force 1918.
The Danish West Indies were sold in 1917.
The Spanish Flu took about fifteen thousand Danish lives.
The Reunification was on the fifteenth of June, 1920, and the Kanslergade Agreement on the thirtieth of January, 1933.
In Episode Four, the Germans arrive.
Now it is time for your exam practice.
These are real questions from past Danish citizenship exams on what you just heard.
For each one, I will read the question and the choices, then pause so you can pick your answer, and then I will give you the correct answer.
Question 1.
Was Denmark occupied by German troops during the First World War?
Option A: Yes.
Option B: No.
[DA] Var Danmark besat af tyske tropper under 1. verdenskrig (1914-18)?  A: Ja  |  B: Nej
The answer is B: No.
It appeared in the June 2022, November 2023 and November 2025 exams.
[DA] ✔ B: Nej
Question 2.
In connection with which war was Denmark hit by the Spanish Flu?
Option A: The Second Schleswig War.
Option B: The First World War.
Option C: The Second World War.
[DA] I forbindelse med hvilken krig blev Danmark ramt af influenzaepidemien Den Spanske Syge?  A: 2. Slesvigske Krig  |  B: 1. Verdenskrig  |  C: 2. Verdenskrig
The answer is B: The First World War.
It appeared in the November 2021 and May 2023 exams.
[DA] ✔ B: 1. Verdenskrig
Question 3.
When was North Schleswig, today called South Jutland, reunited with Denmark?
Option A: 1864.
Option B: 1901.
Option C: 1920.
[DA] Hvornår blev Nordslesvig, i dag kaldet Sønderjylland, genforenet med Danmark?  A: 1864  |  B: 1901  |  C: 1920
The answer is C: 1920.
It appeared in the November 2021 and May 2024 exams.
[DA] ✔ C: 1920
Question 4.
When was the land border between Denmark and Germany last changed?
Option A: 1720.
Option B: 1820.
Option C: 1920.
[DA] Hvornår er landegrænsen mellem Danmark og Tyskland sidst blevet ændret?  A: 1720  |  B: 1820  |  C: 1920
The answer is C: 1920.
It appeared in the November 2024 exam.
[DA] ✔ C: 1920
Question 5.
When did Denmark get its first female minister?
Option A: 1924.
Option B: 1947.
Option C: 1975.
[DA] Hvornår fik Danmark sin første kvindelige minister?  A: 1924  |  B: 1947  |  C: 1975
The answer is A: 1924.
It appeared in the November 2020, November 2023 and June 2026 exams.
[DA] ✔ A: 1924
Question 6.
When did Denmark get its first Social Democratic prime minister?
Option A: 1871.
Option B: 1924.
Option C: 1966.
[DA] Hvornår fik Danmark sin første socialdemokratiske statsminister?  A: 1871  |  B: 1924  |  C: 1966
The answer is B: 1924.
It appeared in the November 2020 exam.
[DA] ✔ B: 1924
Question 7.
Who was Denmark's first Social Democratic prime minister?
Option A: Thorvald Stauning.
Option B: Jens Otto Krag.
Option C: Anker Jørgensen.
[DA] Hvem var Danmarks første socialdemokratiske statsminister?  A: Thorvald Stauning  |  B: Jens Otto Krag  |  C: Anker Jørgensen
The answer is A: Thorvald Stauning.
It appeared in the November 2021 and May 2023 exams.
[DA] ✔ A: Thorvald Stauning
Question 8.
In which decade was Thorvald Stauning prime minister?
Option A: The 1930s.
Option B: The 1950s.
Option C: The 1970s.
[DA] I hvilket af følgende årtier var Thorvald Stauning statsminister?  A: 1930’erne  |  B: 1950’erne  |  C: 1970’erne
The answer is A: The 1930s.
It appeared in the November 2024 exam.
[DA] ✔ A: 1930’erne
Question 9.
What problems was the Kanslergade Agreement of 1933 meant to solve?
Option A: Economic problems.
Option B: Environmental problems.
Option C: Integration problems.
[DA] Hvilke problemer i samfundet skulle Kanslergadeforliget fra 1933 især løse?  A: Økonomiske problemer  |  B: Miljømæssige problemer  |  C: Integrationsproblemer
The answer is A: Economic problems.
It appeared in the June 2021, November 2022 and May 2025 exams.
[DA] ✔ A: Økonomiske problemer
That's the end of this part.
Well done.